vladimir putin presiding his most senior
officials seated at a covert proof
distance
the main reason for today's security
council we need to listen to our
colleagues and define future steps in
that direction taking into account the
appeal of the heads of the
self-proclaimed ligand scandanese
people's republics to recognize their
independence and the russian parliament
on this topic
the u.s secretary of state predicted
last week that russia would manufacture
a crisis and theatrically convene
emergency meetings to address it and
that is exactly what's happening
pictures of women and children shipped
from donbass to russia filling the
airwaves over the weekend seventy
thousand so far supposedly to protect
them from an imminent ukrainian
offensive which ukraine categorically
denies
today reports of a russian border guard
post blown up by supposed ukrainian
forces with claims too that a group of
five infiltrated russian territory
before they were eliminated again flatly
denied by ukraine
the kremlin playbook is an overused
phrase but events over the last few days
do seem to be following a pre-ordained
path set in motion by the video message
announcement last week of the evacuation
of donbass which it turns out was
pre-filmed two days in advance since
then events have been taking an
all-too-familiar path signposted in
advance by the west swallowed at face
value by a large part of the russian
public
today russia's defense minister warned
of ukrainian escalation and pointed to
what he called the country's dangerous
nuclear ambitions
i would like to draw the attention of
the members of the security council to
the statement of mr zielenski that they
suppose they would like to return to
regain the status of a nuclear country i
do not want to say power but country it
is extremely dangerous
and so on the recommendation of his
security council a couple of hours later
this announcement from the president i
believe
to take the decision that has been uh
been asked to be made
uh for a long time to
recognize the independence of donetsk
and lugansk people's republics i would
like the federal uh
[Music]
union
to
support and then ratify the agreement
between
uh peacekeeping and support between the
uh countries and these documents will be
signed
as soon as possible many in the west and
kremlin watchers too believe he won't
stop there the worst uh scenario that we
can expect
is that uh putin can
can go
to the kiev
to keep
and uh
in his logic
the only way to
obtain the guarantees that ukraine will
never join nato
is to make ukraine to
disappear
as a state in the current state
russia's army is poised for action in
attack positions along three sides of
ukraine's east it may not be long now
before all the west's worst predictions
come true
dinah magnay sky news moscow